all right let's take one more call let's
go to nathaniel in columbia south
carolina what's up nathaniel
hey how's the next big uh talk show
personality doing
right i keep telling everybody that we
only have like 42 people who listen to
this podcast but we're gonna get there
brother we're gonna get there ah
you're a star in the making hold up how
are you man
well i can't complain a lot going on but
i think that describes most of us so
you know i'm not gonna complain very
cool so what's up brother how can i help
well i noticed that there's a lot of i
would call impulsive behaviors not major
things but
uh that i um have a habit of doing
and it's affecting my life in small ways
and i just want to know
get some advice on how to control them
better very cool so
talk to me about the impulsive behaviors
well i can think of
a few things in gen in particular one
a little bit of overeating i wouldn't
consider myself like
an overweight person so it's a little
bit hard to talk with people about it
but for instance if i'm at my
my work i'll visit the snack machine uh
on good days three times hello
uh yeah i love snack machines man i'm
with you
yeah yeah uh on bad days where i'm
stress eating it's
five-ish which is not or six i don't
know
uh so that's one thing and then now that
i'm working from home a little bit more
you know oh look it's 10 30 i guess it's
time for lunch number three already
that's right that's right oh that's one
thing and another
area i notice is uh internet time okay
especially during uh work
uh so a lot of my work right now is on
my laptop
and uh i get distracted really easy
watching youtube
um it's kind of frustrating and uh
so yeah so besides eating
and some internet distractions what else
something else is is behind you
something's worrying you what is that
i mean other things is
i think it's more omissions like okay i
should be exercising but let's watch one
more episode of
the john galone show before i go and
five hours later
always okay always okay yeah so
sacrifice your physical i found what i'm
trying to no
kidding um yeah or just our stuff like
oh i guess it's time to
you know uh clean that you know jenga
tower of dirty dishes in my
sink right now but i'll get to it it's
just
irritating stuff like that uh and i
guess what's compounding it a little bit
is one in about three weeks i'm getting
married oh
okay i i i told my fiance about this is
that like
i think i'm a little disappointed in
myself that i imagined i would be a
different person
by this point or like you know i've been
trying to change the behaviors like okay
make a schedule start putting ad block
or not ad blocker site blockers on your
computer
uh stop carrying money to work so you
can't
you know actually buy anything uh you
know and that works for
a week or so and then a distraction or
stress happens
i resort to those as control mechanisms
back to square one gotcha okay
so what would you say brother is that
the root of
your you call them impulsive behaviors
um they're those are
really numbing behaviors they are
ways to unplug real quick or
for a long time and usually those
behaviors are rooted in some sort
of underlying stress
underlying feelings of what's
what's underlying for you man uh
one thing i guess that comes to mind a
lot
is uh my research i'm a i'm a grad
student getting my phd
good for you and i mean i tell people
this quite frankly uh i think my
research is a burning dumpster fire
within a train wreck within a meteor
crater
yes um what are you studying i mean i'm
i'm starting organic chemistry oh that
sounds exciting okay
you actually could literally be studying
inside of a dumpster fire though which
is pretty cool for ochem
um why do you say your research is no
good
uh well i feel like well just talking to
my
advisor i it's
i my last three projects kind of
i worked on it really hard and it turned
essentially my advisor said scrap this
project go somewhere else
um and that's been the case for
the last few years like i'm i mean i'm
still in the program so
hooray and i'm more than halfway
past the halfway point thankfully but uh
a lot of times i don't know if my
advisor is just being a perfectionist
or if i'm actually and he's just i'm
actually doing okay
and he's just trying to push me harder
or it's
you should be really worried right now
and you need to
you know shift gears and i guess
also with
the whole um the big news that's
happening around the world coronavirus
uh i got placed back on ta duty
it's a whole lot more work online
everything is slower
and i just spend most of my time grading
papers as opposed to actual research yep
so that doesn't help the situation
how old are you man that's 25.
okay can you um
let's get in a
let's just back up for a second okay can
you go global with me for a second
okay you're getting married in a few
weeks the world is
literally and figuratively on fire
we're in the middle of a pretty
remarkable pandemic
an absolute economic implosion
you are in the middle of one of the most
difficult ph
phd programs on the planet
real hard a lot of people do a lot of
gymnastics academically to get out of
ochem
and you're getting a phd in it it's hard
what you're doing
most people who aren't in the phd
process don't know how many times you
feel real good about something and your
advisor says that's not good enough do
that again
that happened to me a bunch or rewrite
this
or where did you even get this
information from you need to redo that
again
and my advisors both of them were really
wonderful people
and i still had to redo some stuff
you are in the middle of three of the
most stressful things i can imagine
were you going to school to be a
professor too
uh yes okay so you're also in the middle
of a
you're working towards a career that is
evolving
and changing underneath us all at as we
speak here right
so you are living literally in a true
dumpster fire
everything around you is on fire and one
of the things our brains do
is they love us and try to take care of
us
and so what you've got is a series of
behaviors whether we can call them
little ticks you can call them little
whatevers which are little mini checkout
moments
i'm just going to click off i can't read
one more stupid okay and paper i'm just
gonna spend the next four hours here
i'm gonna procrastinate on this i'm
gonna just have one more meal
because i need one more dopamine hit
that's gonna make that stress a little
bit less
it's gonna cover up my amygdala a little
bit more right it's gonna unhook it a
little bit more
and i want you to number one first and
foremost give yourself some grace
okay you are in
the middle of it it's a lot going on
i also want you to
real like i'm not big on shoulds and
have to's i think some shoulds and i
wish i had
those can weigh people down but you've
got to stop talking to nathan
so badly okay you are beating up nathan
you're talking to yourself in a way that
you would never let somebody talk to
your fiance
right right is that fair
i think that's fair okay so distraction
behaviors
are they're they're just a bomb they're
like chapstick
they're a lie okay think of them like a
lie
um the key here if you want to change a
behavior number one is awareness
when you're about to eat something when
you're about to go to the snack machine
as you start to roll your chair back
because it happens automatically right
i want you to or at your house when you
decide oh man it's time for
first seventh lunch i want you to pause
and say what am i trying to protect
myself from
and just let it sit there for a second
as you're about to eat another sleeve of
cookies i want you to think
huh why am i still eating this
what is my brain trying to protect me
from and it's probably from one more
assignment
one more place where you're going to not
feel enough
one more step towards a job that you
don't even know if it's going to be
there
one more step towards a forever decision
which is getting married
right it's doing its job it's trying to
protect you and what you have to do is
fill your your resiliency bucket if you
will
with positive behaviors instead of
default settings
and so just getting rid of impulsive
behaviors just stopping eating
or just saying i want to be super good
looking for my wedding
i want to be super
good for my professor those are always
going to be trying to fill an internal
hole with external plugs you're going to
be doing something for somebody else for
somebody else for somebody else
and i want you to begin talking to
nathan in a positive way
she began to say i'm gonna eat well
cause i'm gonna feel better my research
is gonna be better
i'm gonna be able to be a better husband
for my wife um
my head's gonna be better not just so
i'm not fat
you know what i mean going towards
something instead of away from something
is totally different
and just recognizing your impulses are
liars
let me give you a sentence that changed
my life
okay uh i struggle with impulse
behaviors
a lot i've got a lot of tics i've
struggled with adhd my whole life and
with anxiety my whole life
and i read a sentence that was from an
adhd scholar that was really
extraordinary for me
and here was the sentence don't forget
to remember
and i know that sounds out of order in a
wacky sentence
don't forget to remember here's what
that sentence means
it means when i pull up to my house i
for some reason i can't see i still have
cds in my car
i can't see the cds that are scattered
all over my car i can't see the water
bottles
and the um you know the lacroix cans in
the car i don't i just don't see it
but i remember what it feels like
getting into a really messy truck
i remember what it feels like to get
into a really clean truck
i forget i'll walk through the house and
i will just leave
crap everywhere i will wake up
and think i don't want to go work out
downstairs
and then i will make sure i don't forget
to remember how good it feels after i've
worked out
how good it feels to actually put stuff
away where it goes
and what it does is it takes me to the
other end not on the front end because
people who struggle with impulse
behavior who struggle with numbing
behaviors who struggle with addiction
who struggle with adhd on the front end
they they struggle with that front end
impulse
what we can control is the back end okay
what we can control
is where we're headed
i don't want to pick that stuff up now
but i don't want to forget to remember
how good it feels
when the house is clean when i how good
it feels when my wife can just relax and
smile because she's worked her butt off
with our kids but all day
and so don't forget to remember as a
sentence that changed my life i hope it
will change yours
i want to tell you man you are in the
middle of it this storm will pass
winter will pass and spring will come
your wedding's going to be awesome
she said she loved you before you
started working out
so she still loves you i don't want you
to work out for her i want you to work
out for you
i don't want you to try to get the next
right phd program for your professor
to try to prove that you belong you do
you got in the program i want you to
work really hard on your research
because we need some great ochem people
out there we got a lot of problems that
ochem folks can help us solve
i want you to do it because you can do
it i want you to
not spend time on the internet brother
because i want you to get your grading
done so you can go outside and go for a
walk
so you can go outside and call your
fiancee and you're going to talk about
what's going to happen four or five
years from now
because you're worth it brother
nathaniel